so the last chance qualifier for the
recent valerian astro clash was this
past weekend and dignitas and fallacy
both earned spots in the main event but
after one of fallacy's players mars
posted a clip from their final match on
twitter some members of the community
began questioning the legitimacy of
their wins to put it simply it looks
like her boyfriend may have been playing
all of the matches instead of her
[Music]
before i get into the video i just want
to let you guys know that we'll be
co-streaming evo on our twitch channel
from august 5th to 7th so if you're into
fighting games then make sure to check
it out this is even flying to canada so
it's going to be a lot of fun alright so
first off let's talk about what exactly
astral clash is it's a tournament hosted
by gen g and gallarants for the best
female identifying valorman players in
north america to compete for a ten
thousand dollar prize pool this past
weekend was the last chance qualifier
for the event and there were two final
spots up for grabs finish top two and
you'd earn yourself a trip to california
to compete in the main event paid for by
gen g when the qualifier got underway on
saturday fallacy looked like one of the
best teams and one of their players was
popping off mars finished their first
two matches with 351 and 295 acs
respectively which was higher than any
other player in the server she continued
to dominate in the semis and even the
finals where fallacy took down dignitas
who are a top 10 team within the game
changers scene according to vlr's
rankings it was an impressive run from
fallacy and after the match mars even
posted this crazy 1v4 ace clutch on
twitter
one enemy
[Music]
it was a pretty solid clutch if you ask
me but this is also where our story
starts to get pretty interesting you see
after mars posted that clip some members
of the community began questioning
whether or not it was actually her plan
later that night the twitter account
nice keybinds posted a google doc titled
account sharing concerns in gallaran's
astral clash the doc suggested that mars
had somebody else play on her account
throughout the entirety of the last
chance qualifier and that they believed
it was her boyfriend and xtsm academy
player pain within the dock are
screenshots comparing all of mars's
settings to payons some of the
screenshots were blurry though so i went
ahead and grabbed some clips from their
twitch channels that relate to the dock
on the left is a clip from mars stream
and on the right is a clip from paying
stream if we look closely then we can
see that mars uses the f key for her
first ability and payon uses the default
key which is c mars uses a cyan dot
crosshair while her boyfriend uses a
white crosshair and you can also see
that payon uses a slightly larger
minimap on top of that payon has also
posted clips on his twitter account that
show him using the discord overlay
something that isn't seen in any of
mars's past clips but is present in the
clip that she posted after the qualify
the dock also mentions that mars fps is
typically lower than what it is in the
clip it's quite a bit higher and in a
similar range to what pan averages now
even after all this i'm sure there are
some of you out there who are thinking
oh well she decided to try out her
boyfriend's settings and yeah that's a
possibility but i'm not sure if a simple
change to her settings could justify the
improved performance within the server
mars acs prior to astral clash was in
the low to mid hundreds but throughout
the last chance qualifier her acs was
291. if we look at payon's profile on
valorent tracker then we can also see
that he was playing ranked with the team
on july 19th without mars i reached out
to both of them for comment but
unfortunately didn't hear back from them
the final section of the google doc
mentions a past controversy with fallacy
they fielded two substitutes in the past
to change their twitter bio to display
non-binary before an event and after the
event one of them even removed it from
their profile so what does this mean
well if the allegations are true then
not only did fallacy break gallaran's
rules by fielding a male identifying
competitor but that would also mean that
mars broke riot's terms of service
section 1.5 of riot's tos states that
you can't share your account or login
credentials with anyone and you can't
sell transfer or allow any other person
to access your account or login
credentials or offer to do so by
breaking riot's tos you aren't just at
risk of losing the ability to compete
you're at risk of losing the ability to
play the game altogether if they
terminate your account but as long as
events or qualifiers continue to be
played online situations like this could
keep popping up genji did release a
statement today announcing that team
fallacy are suspended from competing in
the astral clash live finals and that
they will not be permitted in any
gallerance tournaments until riot
finishes their investigation riot
haven't released a statement at the time
of writing this but this just adds to a
long list of problems within the game
changer scene it seemed as though almost
every week there's some sort of drama
and riot notoriously haven't always
pleased the community with their rulings
game changers is meant to be a place
where women and marginalized genders can
compete and grow within the community so
i hope riot steps up and fixes things
because right now there are some people
making a mockery of it and it's not fair
to those who want to play and feel safe
while doing so
[Music]
you